this show is sponsored by betterhelp and
as the world's largest therapy service
better help us Match 3 million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapists learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday that's betterhelp
health.com trash Tuesday
thank you to our sponsor rocket money
cancel unnecessary subscriptions with
rocket money today go to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday seriously it could save
you hundreds per year that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday thank you
to our sponsor next Evo the holidays are
in all sleigh bells and mistletoe there
are also airports shopping malls and
dining tables crowded with people some
you're glad to only see once a year get
smarter CBD from next Evo Naturals and
get up to 25 off subscription orders of
forty dollars or more at nextevil.com
podcast promo code trash Tuesday that's
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com slash podcast promo
code trash Tuesday hi guys I am going to
be doing stand-up in Phoenix January 6th
and 7th you can get tickets at Esther
onice.com and also check out my solo
show my pleasure it's available wherever
you listen to your podcasts what's up ho
ho hoes Merry Christmas what a fun
episode what last I had after enjoying
this show you can go over to Annie wood
which premieres every Tuesday after
trash Tuesday at noon Pacific time it's
been so fun it is my solo Little Dream
project thank you guys so much for being
a part of it I can't wait to see you
there I also am on the road this New
Year's I am at Wise Guys in Las Vegas
which is everything I love gambling I
love partying and I love doing comedy so
come do that with me that'll be January
30th and 31st and then you can see me at
Burbank Flappers one night only January
7th in January I will also be in
Wisconsin I will be in Florida in
February and March and in Canada a lot
more dates are being added so just go to
annieleterman.com shows
I can't believe we haven't met till now
this is crazy yeah to be fair I don't
leave home much I don't either unless
I'm working well there you go yeah I
don't like going you're never meant to
cross
no we were destined to and again I never
go to The Comedy Store yeah have you
ever seen me there I saw you there one
time you and Rudy went together well
before I worked on bad friends but I
knew Bobby a little bit and I saw you
guys there and I was like oh cool
they're here but I didn't meet you then
oh right I think I remember because it
was like the only time I went there last
year yeah you probably know exactly what
the one night
um
oh you guys have not met each other no
can we intro juicy too oh my God all
right guys welcome an Eagles jacket this
is a trash Tuesday it's it's green at
this point the Eagles have won but is it
over yet no it's not over at this point
the Eagles are about to win
um we are this is Christmas Day we are
not pre-recording this and this is Santa
this is Jew Santa I don't know I like to
oh I don't you Santa do you always drink
out of a mug of your own face
I'm famous baby this is my body too uh
this is very similar to what I've the
weight I've gained over this year so
this is whatever Annie Sansa knocked
over the menorah pretty violently oh
Santa struck the menorah to the ground
yeah being an anti-semite is she an
anti-semite are they Santa by the way
Santa's non-binary and not dealing with
the [ __ ] Jews right now okay awesome
a big Kanye fan yeah Kanye is gonna get
a lot of presents for me this year okay
listen you know what Kanye's gonna get
because yeezy's contract back all right
and guess who's gonna enjoy it the most
the [ __ ] Jews that are mad at him
let's be real
um okay we have uh Jesse juicy jet ski
Johnson it's me it's been me the whole
time the whole time
um we have you may know kalila um very
very looks very similar to my favorite
male comedian Kyle
you think people have been saying that
all week and I just don't see it that's
our best bet
that's our best Kyle fan art I think we
should do it I think Kyle should come
back on as a guest wait maybe one time
when you're not available
look at this fat you know why my lashes
are long when I was a little girl and I
I cut my eyelashes because I thought
they were too long and my mom was like
that mortified she looked like that
because she just I was like seven and I
had a scissors so close to my eyes
but I think they grew back quickly I had
a mean girl do that to me in high school
she cut your eyelashes she was like
because I was like I don't have any
eyelashes because you know Asian and she
was like oh yeah I know the solution to
that she's like just trim your lashes so
I did I already didn't have any oh no
and now I was completely eyeballed for
like the like months out of the school
year and I was like where's my and then
she laughed about it for like six months
I
um
listen guys I was in high school with
Kyla
and shot of all your eyelashes I'll show
you [ __ ]
what am I sitting on
it
I was like what is this thing that feels
so nice up my kukanu I cook a loon
um okay so I didn't get to bring
presents this year I don't know if you
remember the presents I got last year we
were in Hawaii I remember I still have
it the calendar I got you a hot boy
calendar Esther a hot girl calendar
because she's a lesbo and then I got
George just a calendar of Hawaii because
he had brought his family and he didn't
get to go do anything because his baby
was like crying all day
so I brought him like this is the
vacation he could have had
uh it was a good burn aspirational
calendar
um and I just got me one so I could
learn to count but
um what I would have gotten this year is
I would have gotten do you smoke weed a
little bit not much anymore okay so I
was I like the ideas of getting people
presents that are like seem nice but are
actually life ruining oh so I wanted to
get you a three foot bong because that
is like so bad I had one once and my
life spiraled out of control
um yeah but it's such a fun present to
get you're like oh my God this is the
greatest present and then slowly
everything falls away everything you've
worked for is gone you're alone you're
divorced your kids have left you don't
even have any I get married and then
divorce yes that's what happened after
we smoked um that one episode we
recorded you got divorced no well I
ended up smoking every day for like five
straight days well I was considering
giving it to you but I don't actually I
work with you like I don't work with her
that much so it's like you're my actual
business partner so I can't have you
actually spiral up but with jet ski it's
like yeah she could miss a day or two on
the road
you could have her not show up the hair
honestly the Mrs Claus hairs that goes
with it
the bomb
doesn't she look she look like a
barrister like one of those a Barrington
Bears steam is that what you mean no
like in in they're lawyers right in
England they have to oh a barrister
order kind of look like a cartoon bear
yeah
not like the ass wiping ones but like
the ones are childhood not Charming yeah
you don't seem Charming
um oh my gosh look yep that's me
oh my God
oh look at you so cute it's the curls
and everything I do kind of like it it's
like if you want to get this sort of
paycheck and have this sort of power as
a lawyer you're gonna have to humiliate
Yourself by wearing this shitty wig why
do they do that still I know it's like
tradition but and why is it made
actually out of yarn well the women have
to wear it too which I find so silly
like have you seen Amal Clooney in it no
can you pull that up and I know it's
like respect to the institution and the
tradition of it all but I just oh my
it's just funny and so funny
also get it to match but you can see
your roots
the question is like does it have to be
blonde like if I was a brunette couldn't
I ask to be like hey can I get like I
want to be a ginger I want to be a
ginger lawyer they don't trust those
though gingers we know you're up to
something
more and it's not Justice it's not
Justice Just to create like uniform in
the system is what it's saying on how
stuff works that's ridiculous but why
was it why is it blonde is that your job
do you think just looking up how
stuffworks.com is that like one of your
have you even bookmarked it never been
on this site and I'm like hmm this site
would really help me this could have
helped you out your [ __ ] job you're
now admitting you have
it's so funny wait can I just tell you
it's so funny that I thought there was a
bigger liquid death I go oh look what
death camera with like a 40.
and it's just a Modelo
I have a question what were the big
drinks when you were in high school like
for me it was like Mad Dog 2020 Alize
was like top shelf for me
um I think Boone's Farm was like very
young fun so cool yeah oh like alcohol
ones yeah uh Four Loco
yeah me too my friend would go buy them
for me and I would drink them alone in
my room oh my God you were meant to have
a three foot bomb look at you that was
one of the first things I smoked out of
and it was this girl was I think I was
16 and she was 21 and we worked at the
same coffee shop and I thought she was
so cool and I went to her house and
that's always the beginning of the end
when you look up to someone I looked up
to her so much and she was like I went
to her house and I was still in high
school but and she I don't know why she
was hanging out with me in the first
place but she gave me this like three
four foot bong I had to stand on the
table to smoke it and she lit the bowl
and I just the teamwork of it is kind of
special you can't do it by yourself yeah
so I was like oh cool I'm smoking with
Corinne
next thing I know I'm like in her
bedroom just like rocking back and forth
you're fired he's never Zoo again she
wasn't even my boss she was like at one
point she's like you're gonna have to go
home now oh that's so sad when it's like
but you did this to me [ __ ] I know one
uh Mother's Day and I think I might have
recycled it several times for Mother's
Day on Instagram I um I like I put a hat
on the top of my three foot bong and
then I looked like I was putting its
backpack on I was like go to school
little one it was like one of my best
Mother's Day is a big trigger for me
because my I had to perform the heimlich
maneuver on my own mother on Mother's
Day as she was choking on Rice I don't
know why I heard Heim and I thought
there was gonna be a Hyman involved
this is actually a better story than
where I thought I was going I had to do
a hymenectomy on my mom her hymen had
grown back I had to burst that cherry
open I for sure cracked open my hymen
before I lost my actual virginity
because I ran into I was biking high
speeds around my neighborhood and I I
drove right into a wall and I swear to
God that bike seat impaled my [ __ ] my
young little [ __ ] it's so weird you're
saying this right now because the shorts
I have to wear under this are so far up
my [ __ ] that it's Cutters it's the most
painful and it does feel like a hymen
will be popped I mean yours is probably
well
[ __ ]
Santa's going down wow Santa let me tell
you the other present I was gonna get
you [ __ ]
I have this fantasy that I'm gonna meet
a really nice man and we're going to
start on only fans and it's basically
the slow progress this is her beautiful
story of him feeding me into morbid
obesity and I'm going to call it only
hams I love that's a good idea because
not only this is a good idea but people
will pay to watch this happen yeah yeah
I like the slow progression also another
thing I want to do is I want to find the
brother that I might have had sex with
that whose DNA we haven't really
confirmed yet and I want him to do the
DNA test and in the event that he is in
fact my brother I want to start an only
fans
guys here's the thing and but then we
only touch elbows there's no Sexes she's
also gonna do on what she's going to do
them with a stepbrother she did [ __ ] but
he does so it's going to be called only
sand because it's now ashes
all right all right I love you
um only hams is great I call my fans
hams I'm like Oh my hams wait in the
future or you do now this is a billion
dollars wait I'm sorry do you have like
a whole side hustle where you call your
friend's hands now
look I cannot call anyone you're being
extra fun today I've been smoking weed
everyday this is great
it saved Esther too
I'm like can't I become the worst I'm
become the opposite
um I have faith in you you're gonna
cycle back into I'm not trying to make
100 million dollars I made that deal to
myself and I'm not gonna make a million
dollars you're not gonna have fun until
you make 100 no I always have fun at fun
all day I'm not gonna smoke weed again
which actually takes my fun oh my God
it's not a fun bet yeah why not that's
good it's healthy it's crazy yeah
healthy it's healthy to think you're
gonna make 100 million dollars yeah
that's healthy Lucy do you have any only
fans fantasies or like ideas oh yeah
tell your idea did you have a balloon
animal
somebody because telling me I oh you
should start oh go on the feeling it's
always our friends it's like our guy
friends yes do you want to watch me
finger myself like for 20 bucks in the
bathroom what are you doing this gone
Felix said the story is like uh oh you
got to get an only fence and I was like
I don't wanna
get it only fancy because you don't have
to do sex stuff and I said people aren't
gonna pay to watch me do like balloon
animals
because I'm goofy like guys comment
below and she's fully clothed and she
might be in the Santa thing if you're
into it
because it takes away from sex workers
but I do like how Whitney did it that's
a good point Whitney did a her roast on
there a bit it's because people are I
noticed with Whitney who I love that
people just want to take her down no
matter what so they might as well pay
for her content if they're just gonna
slam it yes thank you uh now you look
like an authority because Annie
you think sorry that er only fans is
going to take away from sex workers
guys that are like going to jerk off are
going to be like you know I only have
ten dollars
herself or the girl make the dog with
the [ __ ] poodle fail I can't even
make balloon animals maybe that's the
journey oh but Annie they might be both
under the category of POV that's why but
wait
your only hams what I like is they're
like today I'm getting a hot beef
injection but it really is just him
injecting beef into your mouth it's
actually beef
it's not a stiff one I've always really
been into the idea of like feederism as
sort of like this the ultimate [ __ ] you
where I'm like you know what like I'm
ready to just let go of myself
completely yeah I mean what could you do
it deep throats big hug
that's really uh
like an actual penis of a pig I don't
know it's your own hands wait I do like
me because I hog the conversation
really into pigs
listen watch the Whitney Rose I know
what a big pig I am no no I was like not
out yet no no it's not out yet but by
this time I don't think so it'll be out
yet I think I don't know her who knows
it was so fun though I got to watch it
and Annie killed it you really did thank
you your jokes were great
um one of my favorite ones on the panel
I also liked Bob the drag queen a lot oh
Bob drag queen yeah Bob the dragon
crushed crushed but yeah you handled
everything I think that would be so hard
I never done any kind of roasting to
like hear everyone just making fun of
you and you just have to be like well
the only ones that are annoying are when
they're like lies yeah for me not for
anyone else because it's not like a
well-crafted joke well it's also just
like that's my my like one of my highest
values is just honestly so like it
pisses I always realize like whenever
I'm like triggered it's because like I'm
like oh because in my head the most
important thing is being honest but
these people don't give a [ __ ] they're
just getting laughs they don't [ __ ]
care at all it is and they don't have to
care I'm not right over them it's just
like the thing I like so I'm getting all
pissed but it would be like you know
like she's never even seen her dad my
Jesus God
I talked to five times already today
yeah how about him on every episode I
know I guess it hurt my feelings
well I think they didn't do their
research that's what probably hurt your
feelings well because the exciting thing
about Rose is like really being seen
even it's like if it's a mean thing like
call me fat it's like [ __ ] it is I
gained a lot of weight it's funny but
like it's but like there were funnier
ones like I'm trying to think of like
the best well my favorite joke about me
even though it wasn't very mean was like
um Bob the drag queen was like where do
you get your tan you just go to 7-Eleven
and stand in front of the hot dog
machine
wait wasn't there a really good Bobby
calila joke there yes Robin Tran please
post a picture of Robin Tran okay Robin
Tran is what um
as if Bobby and kalila kept to the baby
oh yeah
it was really good
it was really good but Rob and Tran had
really good jokes too but Robin trans
were like very like you can tell she
like researched everyone she went in
hard yeah it was really good but Robin I
had one about Robin because Robin
um I think allegedly is the one that got
this guy writing that said Joe Rogan is
literally five three oh it's rumored to
have been here and so I wrote I said
that's ironic because she literally she
transitioned into literally a five oh
wait literally she transitioned
literally from a five to a three yeah I
remember that joke that was awesome but
yeah we were very brutal to her she got
it she was mean to me back but I think
you can be more mean to the people who
you know are gonna bring it right
because she's such a good writer yeah
yeah well I think like she and I really
do and Bob like I don't even know if Bob
spent a lot of time or not but I didn't
know Bob was I didn't even know about
Bob Bob is everything I was like
Bob the drag queen is like if a drag
queen's like that's their Olympic sport
but listen she identified she he
whatever you want Robin I'll call you
whatever you want or Bob I mean I'll
call you whatever you want Bob or
everything except Robin sorry you do not
identify as Robin but Bob the drag queen
was [ __ ] unbelievable
um crazy good what do you guys
um what do you guys want for Christmas
this year
what are some big asks from both the
universe and the people that you love
uh I'd really like some new towels
what kind do you have are you kidding
I'm just kidding I'm like I know what
we're doing in San Jose
spoil my openers happening this weekend
even though we didn't Bank this is
Christmas these guys don't steal um
Hotel towels no but that would be great
I have a traumatizing memory of that my
dad and mom they're two biggest fights I
may have mentioned one of them on here
already the first fight they're
screaming it sounds physical we can hear
just bum bum bum like you can tell
they're wrapped in each other's arms and
they're banging against walls and we're
like what is happening are they about to
fist fight and they burst through the
kitchen door they come out we're like in
the living room they bust through the
door and then out pops and rolls to my
feet a thing of icing and they were
fighting over the sizing I just both
wanted the icing so bad there's like a
tub of it yeah they're icing pigs they
love my parents oh they're piggy icing
people
chatting with my parents they will stab
each other over the corner piece like
they just love icing my dad will be
known to bring his own icing to add on
top on my dad's 80th birthday 50 people
brought him icing like everyone knows my
dad I've never heard of anything like
people I love my parents I love pig
people but okay so we know
ice cream yeah it is disgusting it's
disgusting
and now they have a fat daughter
um
no I just was like it's fine I'm fat but
you're fat where does the towel come in
with it okay so then that was the other
one okay so then the other fight my
mom's screaming at my dad Scott what are
you teaching the children
what are you teaching them and we just
go in and we've been in like at
Disneyland or something and my dad just
unfolds like four white ass towels and
my mom's like they know you've stole
those and I was like we wouldn't have
[ __ ] noticed if you didn't scream it
but that was a big fight so now I never
she was your mom was mad that your dad
had stolen and that we would then have
the we would see that he stole oh I see
out of like um you know be the example
which is the opposite of Todd's family
who has trained him to be the best thief
of all wow me too it's amazing I think
it's Asian people the best is if you get
away with it one of the most gratifying
feelings she let people steal all of her
you never press charges right no I know
yeah yeah people will follow you for me
it's fair game if you can steal for me
it's yours that's how I feel like if you
can cheat on me and I don't find out
did you cheat I mean sometimes it's like
I would do
no you didn't that does not count for
Todd Todd will be dead on the ground I
was gonna say for all of my other
boyfriends who did definitely cheat on
me wait so
um I mean my I would steal you guys know
this like I would go to Outback
Steakhouse and steal all the utensils
they are pretty good knives and we did
good Outback she took me to Outback it
was a special one of our first dates
yeah
and I'm not gonna lie she did [ __ ] all
over it she was like well actually
Santino took me to like a real
Steakhouse was it um oh
maestros that's where you guys went we
went there Mom yes but then Santino took
me on the road and took me to a
different steak dinner
well he is a ginger so I will always be
superior to him you have to step up your
steak game I well I also am a little bit
I still lean into the way trashness you
see the tan
it's uh it's fun to go down back yeah
but I think so too I love canned ravioli
forever oh yeah I used to eat that Chef
Boyardee Chef boy I will say though that
waiter was the worst waiter I've ever
had in my entire life yeah he was a
problem he was a little pushy
and we didn't order let's just say we
didn't order we were just brought food
that we didn't want no it's like Omakase
but it wasn't the good food I was like
that I have a plan here wait juicy I
want to know what else is on your list
outside yeah what's on your list but was
towels serious
um well I've like those are the kind of
things on my list just like I don't need
but by the way towels are the hardest
thing to shop for because I think
they're a lot most of them are really
not absorbent and when do you have time
to go get some towels you know like
that's not on my list but the coochie
Cutters
I learned this from from like go-go
dancers do you wear these leggings and
you don't have cellulite
so much mine's just gonna pop out even
more oh oh it's so having these nails
with yeah how do you do anything
everything's been hell it's been
horrible we have towels for juicy I feel
like everything is going so I'm so happy
right now with all the things in my life
and and then the next year things are
like they're gonna I told Annie they're
gonna have me headline San Jose Improv
next year when a Wednesday January 18th
Wednesday January 18th you guys good
tickets go see juicy and you guys
probably already saw her do like a
little bit of time on my show in San
Jose so go back and see her it's all
it's perfect because we're there we went
there and we haven't been there yet it's
not that we're going tomorrow
uh we went months ago
we wouldn't bank that far ahead that's
rude it's almost rude
Annie do you ask um for Christmas
presents at all no I have there's not
one thing I can think I want you guys
don't say like exchange like hey this is
what I want this year and like exchange
lists with your family I'm so I listen
I've never had Christmas face presents
getting presents is really stressful do
you like receiving presents are you just
like oh I like giving presents but no
I'll take presents now it's I I love
yeah it's I but it took me a while
because I used to just get so like I
don't know I just like if I didn't like
like it I would feel pressured to look
like I liked it and I'm like not a good
liar so then I just start crying and
then it was like way worse than just not
getting me a present right I like
presents but I love giving yeah you do
is my [ __ ] yeah we play this game Daddy
Warbucks over here oh yeah I think I'm
kind of a Daddy Warbucks yeah like what
we do in my family is or Bobby and I for
the past couple years is we'll buy like
five or maybe four big ticket items like
a Traeger grill and then a Lisa trigger
Grill wow the Traeger grill when she
grows it hurts I'll tell you that and
then rough cookie we'll get a box fill
it with rocks and wrap it up like a
pretty Christmas present and people draw
numbers and it's a hit or miss you
either get the bag of rocks or you get a
Traeger grill and then people but if you
get the Traeger grill you can only get
someone can challenge you for it once
and once only so people but you don't
know violent aggressive angry and like
leave crying and that's the kind of
Christmas that I desire
oh no I like a little squid games not to
be racist a little stupid games of sorts
one time my uncle gave my cousin a car
key and she was like started crying and
she went outside and she was looking for
it and then we were all laughing because
there was so cold
she was like legit mad for a long time
looking around like I believe
[Music]
Annie how do you get your day started I
get my day started I get up all right I
give Randy a little tongue kiss I put on
his leash and then I go into the kitchen
and I make some athletic greens I shake
them up it's easy I put a packet in or
put in a scoop put in my Water Shake It
Up take my dog for a walk and chug my
salad for the day baby I'm back home and
I've already had all my salad for the
entire day
with one delicious scoop of athletic
greens you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right this
special blend of ingredients supports
your gut health your nervous system your
immune system your energy recovery focus
and aging all of the things it tastes so
good too it tastes great it's easy you
don't have to chew do you not want to
chew I wake up with a sore jaw sometimes
I don't have to chew and I've got all of
my vitamins and it's lifestyle friendly
whether you eat keto paleo vegan dairy
free or gluten-free it costs you less
than three dollars a day you're
investing in your health and it's
cheaper than your cold brew habit and it
just eliminates any kind of like
guesswork about what I'm gonna eat that
day to meet my body's needs I just have
one scoop cold water my mochester and
then that's it I don't have to worry
about it for the rest of the day it's
delicious and right now it's time to
reclaim your health and arm your immune
system with convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into the flu and cold
season it's just one scoop in a cup of
water every day that's it no need for a
million different pills and supplements
to look out for your health to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticreens.com Tuesday again that's
athleticgreens.com Tuesday to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
this show is sponsored by Better Health
you guys it's not a secret we all have a
certain degree of mental illness between
I'm doing good talking about and
unfortunately life doesn't come with a
user manual so when it's not working for
you it's normal to feel stuck and for me
personally I I have the tends and I have
the tendency to get stuck on problem
mode and I and not Solutions mode and
this is where a therapist is really
helpful in my life because they're able
to sort of just give me exits I guess
they're able to call me out and say
kalila you're in this shame spiral or
you're this they're able to basically
see things about me that I'm not maybe I
don't I don't have the awareness for in
that moment also look it's the holidays
you're either with your family being
dragged back to whatever role you were
when you lived with them or you're not
with your family being dragged in
whatever role you're in now you're
they're sad or you're happy but you know
the holidays are a lot and it's a great
time to get help yeah and it's like even
if you have the most perfect family like
like it's it's normal to have really
challenging emotions around the holidays
and this is where therapists who are
trained can help you figure out the
cause of these challenging emotions and
learn productive coping skill as the
world's largest therapy service better
help has matched three million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
and if things aren't clicking you can
easily switch to a new therapist anytime
it couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms
no traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday that's betterhelp help.com
trash Tuesday
we had a company little shop a Shop of
Horrors so
[Applause]
so I'm literally at the bottom of the
the feed chain there and I and I but I
got a 25 limit I got like a candle and
some fairy lights from Target and
wrapped them up and we're exchanging
them and I think you picked a number or
something and the person who got mine
was the CEO so like making more money
than everybody and she looked so
disappointed and it was Anonymous
she was just like oh cool and then I was
just like wow like an iPhone I got a
juicer but not like a like a like a
citrus juicer thing they were all like
that's not that much better than the
scented candle I have a big scented
camera say I was like I'd be so happy
and fairy lights yeah
I have a candle place and Malibu that I
get what do you mean listen I like to
drop when I started making money
no no no I go to Marshalls they're all
we need to up here
I like melon gets yeah wait that's how
you say I think so but candles can make
it too no it's like Malibu something
they have a good a rum one that's great
yeah but these are yeah Malibu's
something it's past the market it's like
this this beautiful furniture place and
they have the best like imported candles
and they're so expensive and they're so
good I don't like spending too much on
candles because you're just like burning
it away it's like I don't spend like ten
dollars more or less it's like the best
part of spending money is just like
burning it it's on it's gone baby I
think it's [ __ ] when you smell it
and it's a really strong scented candle
but when you burn it no smell no scents
come out yeah that's a 10 Marshall
[ __ ] the ones I got one at
Marshall's called donut shop it smells
so good donut shop yeah I'll get you one
by the way this did trigger me having to
apply I don't really think you're fat I
was teasing it oh thank God
but donut shop did remind me to tell you
that so you do it that way you want
I hike a lot listen
I have to for how much I eat I ate and I
eat like counter it that's all I've been
not eating late and it's good for my
gerd I don't think it's done anything
for my weight that's good for my gerd my
rule is like three hours before I sleep
is the last but I never know when I'm
going to sleep though guys I'm a pass
out girl I'm waking up on stairs I have
like a very nice bed at night a
nighttime routine
I wash my face let's just say it when I
wake up in my makeup that's my song
that's all you know who plays that song
Paulie's short and the krustees Polly
sure plays that and the crustace has
been they cover that song would you ever
be a crusty have you been oh it's a
crusty I don't think I'm a crusty yet
maybe when I'm older oh they have to be
old to do yeah he wants to be the best
looking guy in the band so what is a
Crusty just a backup can you look at
Folly store in the crusties they're um
they're like you know you'll see they're
they're old older dudes they're crusty
that's so funny see he wants to be the
youngest most attractive guy in the band
he says oh my God they're just gonna but
they are playing they can play because
they've been around they've been playing
for 70 years he met the guitar player
bill
um in a Starbucks wait I'm at Belle is
Bill the one that looks like Larry David
yes you met him he's awesome he did the
show with him it's so funny yeah he's
great oh wow he does look like Larry
David and he rips he could play like
guitar solos and Starbucks
is he like the ding dong show or like
legit yeah but actually okay okay wait I
want to tell you guys the other things
that I would get you okay here are some
other gifts that are life ruining okay
a fish oh yeah that would what oh
[ __ ] bummer the responsibility and
the better a better one that's even
worse the fish you bring out and the
person's pissed and then the person next
to them laughing that they didn't get
the fish yeah and then you hand them a
turtle
a [ __ ] Turtle enjoy this for 80 years
[ __ ] I got you Something's Gonna
outlive you and then you're like it's a
gift it's not mine no touches no give
backsies I had a turtle named Otis and I
would drop fish and like little guppies
in there for him to eat and one of the
times I dropped in a fish and Otis just
refused to eat this fish like him and
his fish like built a rapport and we
named him Milford and I was dating
he was and then Milford this is how
Milford perished um I had uh I was
getting back together with a boyfriend
but he was a very volatile guy and I
remember him stealing my neighbor's
groceries just for fun but one of the
things that he did when we got into a
fight that night was he took a cup and
he scooped Milford out and Milford had
been cohabitating with Otis at this
point for like
five months and we had gotten attached
to Milford and he's like you see this
and he just swallows Milford
anyways that was my turtle story I'll
probably side I know but it's also
the tiniest but awesome
of the bad things you can do to someone
what if it was a cat
well then I would be worried about his
safety yeah that is true if you can
swallow okay you can steal from me steal
from me if you can swallow a cat
you got a thing when someone steals from
you do you immediately start um accusing
in your mind
I have a list I'm doing a whole I'm on
Dateline I've got the I've got the
interview set up in my head I'm like
going
but okay so I went to the desert
two months ago
um and I was like partying with a bunch
of friends we go out to the desert once
a year it's like a bunch of Doug
stanhope's friends Andy Andrus and a
bunch of people
and you know we do like mushrooms and
stuff we hang out by like a campfire and
the people that work at the place that
we stay there's always like a new weirdo
that's like decided to go to the middle
of the desert for some
weird reason and live and work love
Desert Rats yeah yeah but they always
end up being a little strange yeah so
this one girl she had her no humidity it
dries out their brain yeah it's like
it's more or less than the drying out
but that is a good point I do imagine
that's where I'm from wait where are you
from the desert what part Arizona in
Phoenix
Society this is like there's no like
yeah but I've had a lot I've gone to a
lot of desert parties I know exactly
what you're talking about yeah so this
year there was this girl who was I don't
know what else to call her other than a
[ __ ] liar oh
we go on a walk usually we're all [ __ ]
up and we go is it time for the walk we
have all these like like glowing orbs
and stuff and we walk down the highway
and then we lay in the road and we look
at the stars like we do this every year
she comes with us she's [ __ ] just
lying there's just weird things it was
colder this time I went out so she goes
she goes there's going to be a part of
the night where you give me your jacket
and I went I'm never giving you my
jacket was she flirting I don't know
I think the [ __ ] was cold honestly and
thought that I was going to somehow
mother her so let me get there and she
goes this is the time and I go this is
the time where you learn to get your own
[ __ ] jacket [ __ ] okay the wrong
Annie wrong year maybe two years ago I
would have done this for you a year or
done but you just kept like lying about
her age she just kept lying on she said
she was 21 and we're like [ __ ] you are
40. like stop like she was just so weird
and so creepy right and she was the only
one that wasn't in our group so later we
go back we go on that walk we come back
we're sitting around the campfire this
girl goes to go to bed she can't find
her phone her phone was attached to the
speaker
the speaker's gone the phone's gone
check all the rooms and I'm just like
the only [ __ ] we don't know is the liar
[ __ ] so I'm in my head even though I
think she was with us the whole time and
maybe possibly it could have been her in
my head she did it for attention
yeah or like for there to be like a
thing that she caused she was like that
type of weirdo yeah I know people like
that like they like not even like she
wants a phone or anything but she wants
people to be like running around and she
did it I mean
yeah I don't I could I don't know why
people do stuff like that it makes me
really uncomfortable and now like I like
how you say Annie two years ago would
have fallen for that like I I would have
placated to that but now that I've seen
that type of person many times if I even
get like a hint of it I'm like I do it
180 but you're stuck in the desert
I was able to like I was able to not
like I wasn't rude or anything but I was
able to kind of like put it back yeah
yeah in my family there's a lot of
blatant theft going around
um I had an aunt who would like let's
say for instance we all go to the beach
together and let's say I I'm going in
the water like hey can you hold my stuff
and she's wearing my sunglasses my
Ray-Bans that I just bought and it ten
minutes later you're like where are my
sunglasses she's like your sunglasses no
yeah
and then you don't but in my family you
cannot confront like that's a weird
thing but like two weeks later you see
it on Instagram she's posting with your
sunglasses but you cannot say anything
no one is saying anything could we just
take it we're just like that's just who
she is
allergic to this Behavior I almost
sneezed I would be [ __ ] my family all
we do is confront confront confront
confront nobody could ever steal from
anyone because it's like
but you actually know the theft the
theory in my family my twin brother
would just steal my older brother's
clothes and then put them back like he
hadn't taken them but he's like a slob
so my brother would get like new we all
worked at Gap so we'd all get like new
Gap clothes all the time oh that's so
cute all of you worked again well Timmy
didn't but Max and I worked at my twin
brother and I worked at different gaps
over Christmas so max would work at UH
regular Gap and I'd work at kids Yap and
then we'd go we were seasonal workers
and they were across the hall you wore
that same outfit I wore the same outfit
I was 14. uh
and but we had like the little
walkie-talkies and the little headsets
and we would go to like Channel 13 and
we'd like talk [ __ ] together it was so
cute that's all our little breaks
together
but um anyway so Timmy would get like
his like Gap thing he'd use like our
discount or whatever and Max would take
his Gap stuff out of like the plastic
wear it get a stain on it fold it put it
back in it was like gangster it was so
funny to me like Max and we'd all just
be like crying laughing because it's
like it's funnier than it is a problem
I feel like my family has such different
styles they would never steal for like
we'd never want each other's stuff yeah
I don't think for us it's more a just a
sport at this point oh my God I remember
my Uncle Freddie
never trusted Uncle Freddie no but he
was the victim here Freddy Got Fingered
he really did he actually five fingered
um so my uncle Freddy his son is like a
known like the number one like thief in
my family right so he was like you know
what I'm gonna sleep with my wallet on
me and all of like my prized possessions
on me my watch everything and it's like
the theft is so blatant in my family
like he woke up with nothing not even
his belt whoa his son was just again
with his little ginger finger how do you
say it Ginger no with his little like
gingerly gingerly with his fingers that
was like a gingerbread man are we
talking about Santino I was texting I
got confused I didn't know your brother
was Ginger but he was he expertly just
took everything while my uncle was
asleep like like this holding his things
huh like the Grinch yes that's so crazy
good that's kind of impressive though
naughty list yeah naughty again you're
getting that and then they're the ones
that don't get the box of rocks they get
the [ __ ] girls they get the girl yeah
do you think Lisa traeger's family is
the trigger girls I hope so different
spelling yeah I guess her family came
over from she's so funny she is
hilarious she must be working because I
haven't seen her at the store in a bit
but yeah every time I see her she cracks
me out I had a traditional Christmas
like uh my mom always goes all out and
my dad does too but um we would always
do Yule time with my dad because I grew
up halfway in so we go like we go out to
the the desert why didn't I think you'd
like the wiccan it's so fun we go to the
desert ridge celebrate the wicked
Christmas like tell me everything it's
well it's like a you still do like the
same kind of ceremony like Circle but
it's called the old time and there's a
big cake and it's a yule log I love a
Yola they taste so delicious yes so
[ __ ] good and then I remember like
Yule logs they're cute too yeah they're
cute and
yeah it's like a it's like that part's
all the same but um but then we would
have regular Christmas too at the house
with the Christmas tree and presents and
um a lot of with my parents being
divorced if they didn't communicate that
year I'd get a lot of the same stuff oh
my God but that was damn yeah they're so
good they're so cute and you can put
little elves on them sometimes they put
little elves
yeah and we will like drink a lot and
but it's a good time but you're was your
mom like jealous when she's like it was
it's always it's always like I have a
joke where I'm like now that I'm older
because my parents are split
um they tell me I can choose which house
to go I want to go to for the holidays
I'm like I liked it so much better when
the courts just yeah you know like wait
as it was it not like an amicable when
you choose do you put one of those
things on your head what do you want
oh the judgment
[Laughter]
yeah it was it was amicable but you know
they're still divorce so they're not
like yeah talking on the phone every day
so especially as I'd be surprised yeah
yeah
well they were not a hit podcast
together
but I I don't know they now that it's
like I'm out of school and stuff they
really don't have much reason to talk to
each other so it's just a lot of
planning and you know it just gets
harder to see everybody as people get
older and move on and I like how you're
active Wiccan yeah but was he like an
act of Wiccan like he taught you things
about like yes yes yes he's very
spiritual like him and my stepmom my mom
is too but she just doesn't she's more
agnostic
but I was just gonna say you're like
trans age just like like Esther like you
both are like what age could you be
you're like now that I'm out of school
it's like she looks like she just
graduated from high school like now that
I'm finally
I can't wait to start college
exact same I know working at The Comedy
Store feels like going back to school
though as like a tour guide It's like a
program you're good though you really
don't get into the drama it's great no I
try to dodge it
like people will like call me in the
book did you hear about someone so I'm
like what and then you're like friends
with the person they're talking [ __ ] on
I try to just yeah I try to be accepting
as every with everybody because uh I
just don't want to get involved but do
you guys feel like as you got more uh
well-known
um sometimes I kind of feel like that
I'm becoming a little bit of a Target
in the sense of like if I mess up I
think people would be happy to see me
yeah a little bit not everybody good but
there's a few people when you're getting
to the new level of a video game you
encounter more yeah resistance yes yeah
good so starting to feel that a little
bit you just have to not take it
personally because there's nothing to do
with you yeah yeah I'm trying to like
and then then when I feel that I'd focus
in on like okay I should just be working
on my set like I always been doing and
just focus on that the hurtful part is
if these are people who you considered
your peers and friends at some point
that that's where it's like oh [ __ ]
hey the [ __ ] that talk [ __ ] to me
that spread all the rumors all this
stuff there was this guy when I was in
[ __ ] what club was it
um I was in Salt Lake City at Wise Guys
and this guy that works there he like
does cameras or something and he's also
an open maker he comes around with a
with a notebook and he says what advice
would you give yourself when you were an
open maker like write it I think I know
what you're talking about yeah and so in
the book I wrote everyone that's
spreading rumors about you and talking
[ __ ] on you
um has cankles and quit to have kids I
think we should you know what I've been
to hate cankles are okay yeah ankles are
good they're very sturdy uh you know I
would say I like kenko's better than
skinny a little ankles because for the
safety of the person I have this weird
thing and I've talked about it on here
but I'm really trying to let go of my
fixation with men with girl hips and
I've enjoyed a man with a girl hips I I
have I I was with the guy with girl hips
for five years so now I'm just like so
like focused on looking for that in a
man and if I see it I'm like no thanks
but I'm like why am I this shallow
because it's not it's because you don't
don't like him you're thinking about him
you're putting him and sweet oh andya
tips yeah I wonder what it was I don't
know what no you don't you have the
opposite thank you I think if I know
what that looks like I want guy hit no
you have girl hair it's more just like
uh it's not even like a big like a very
hippie look it's just more um it doesn't
go in like this I see so it kind of like
bubbles out ever so slightly and they
kind of like have uh uh like yeah I
don't know it's it's a look I can't
really explain yeah
let's just say
the bottom heavy boys have found their
way to Annie Letterman before
the rainbow of sizes and shapes those
apple bottom boys
have found their pie crust in me
[Laughter]
but I like troubles I just don't like
hips I yeah I don't have the biggest
belly just like it cannot like move down
to your it's just so funny I was looking
at Todd when we were in the desert and I
always am like Todd's always his hottest
in the desert for some reason I don't
know why he's he's just such a man he's
helping around camp and he's just you
know not that he's not always doing
everything but
I was like it's so gonna end up with
like such a hot tall handsome guy like I
don't care where I've been
how did it happen
I never thought I would I always thought
I'd end up with a row I'll go a little
way past topped you know we best popped
it I way past popped
you're right sometimes I'm like do I
deserve this cute boy oh like this boy's
so cute
such a hottie what is going on with the
new Squeaky boots
is there something happening with the
squeaky boots
oh yeah here we go you're very fall
colored for uh Christmas why are you
acting like it's November
inspired me to go get uh new boots at
All Saints they're so squeaky I know
they're a little squeaky right now
they're honestly the most squeaky thing
I've ever heard about the most they're
so sweet they're pretty loud how do I
unscreen and they shift around maybe
loosen them oh Jesus they're tightly you
got to do something military school so
I'm like tightening not for long enough
but right I didn't go for long enough
and it didn't stick wait how long were
you in military school for just [ __ ]
two weeks oh my God he's a rich kid he
got his ass out it goes Dad no yeah
Daddy no I went to McDonald's right
after
that's bad
I need I would do a McDonald's ew oh I
love McDonald's don't act like you're
the one without the eating disorder I'm
teasing you because you're manorexic
manorexic he's a Manor accident I never
heard that before really look it up
you're like really I hear it every day
he's like really it's a very real
disorder he's proud of it I think I am
you are manoxic
a man who thinks it's a truck that's
Urban Dictionary a man who thinks it's
attractive to be skinny and lacking in
muscle mass or any outward physical
appearance of masculinity
oh the most amusing example
oh but do you kind of relate to it no
because I do lift weights at the gym in
my building you're super tone thank you
thank you but like girl toned no I'm not
girl toned I would say model tone thank
you girl model tone
you are everyone's in a good mood today
everyone there's a good amount of high
[Music]
okay so I went on a fun weekend with a
couple of my friends and I found out
that my friend does not watch our
podcast because he told me that he
cancels his credit card every two months
because he doesn't know what
subscription or what subscriptions he
has well I don't blame him like a lot of
these companies make it really difficult
to cancel these subscriptions and
sometimes I don't know what I'm signing
up for because it's like oh I want this
app in this moment and I completely
forget like two years after I'm like why
do I have an insect finder oh yeah I'll
cancel this and this before the seven
day trial it'll be it's five years later
I'm like oh my God I gave them fifteen
thousand dollars are you guys wasting
money on subscriptions eighty percent of
people have subscriptions they forgot
about
um definitely Annie and I yeah but maybe
for you it's an unused Amazon Prime
account or a Hulu account that never
gets streamed rocket money is a great
app that we use to help us track all of
our expenses and because of it we no
longer waste money on subscriptions we
don't even use
look I found out that I have two apple
IDs
double I mean it's crazy you guys it's
helped me it saved so much money that's
why I love using rocket money money
formerly known as trubo and Rocket money
can even find subscriptions you didn't
know you were paying for you may even
find out that you've been double charged
for a subscription and to cancel a
subscription all you have to do is press
cancel and Rocket money takes care of
the rest do you want to know a
subscription that I'm having so much
trouble and I have to use my rocket
money for I have to use my rocket money
to get rid of I am paying for four Tans
a month
or spray tans a month like that do if
you've ever gotten a spray tan it takes
like two weeks for it to come off your
body to get another one is it just an
auto refill they come no they come spray
me but you get like you pay for the
month and then you pay for them to come
to your but it's like I'm not getting
all this spray tans I would look crazy I
would be canceled out of this out of
this business so fast if I got that many
spray tans get rid of useless
subscriptions with rocket money now go
to rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
seriously it could save you hundreds per
year that's rocketmoney.com trash
Tuesday
I don't like it no more because I quit
and I I have a piece of trash what I
don't like it no more I don't like it no
more
whenever I see it on my list Santa's
getting riled up that's naughty
we're on the bad list how long do you
smoke and why'd you quit I smoked for
over a decade and I I quit in April
So and I've quit before that too and but
for like over a year and then I started
during the pandemic and then I quit
again in April
and how do you feel do you are you
getting the the purging kind of cough
I'm well over that uh but I did and I
feel like so like all this momentum in
my career that's been happening it
happened like right around when I quit
smoking as well and I think I don't know
if it's specifically because of that or
if just like maybe when you
actively make positive changes in your
life sometimes things tend to follow and
I and I really think that because Polly
was like I'm wanting to take me on the
road but
um he noticed how much I chain smoked at
work and I think he would have taken me
anyway but he was really happy to hear
that I wasn't smoking that much because
he likes to work with people that take
care of their health
um and I think I don't know I just a lot
of things happen I've been hiking more
and because I can now that it stops I
like inspirational Santa yeah I think
you're right because I think like you
know behind the scenes or even if you're
not conscious about it you're doing
something really nice for yourself yeah
and then you're allowing yourself to be
nice to yourself I think and then you
start allowing nice things to happen for
you after you got to put yourself on the
nice list yeah no one's putting you on
there but listen Santa guys I'm so sorry
it's not real you're Santa
you got to take care of yourself you got
to put yourself on the good list can you
make me a fade away from the chair
guys the snow is above and beyond how
are you guys able to do this
Annie that was five dollars from Target
on Sunset five dollars that's the
Splurge
I like how you laid it up
I feel like Pete really did like judge
it I feel like Pete was like
am I right Pete you're just making sure
the snow is visible on the wide he's
like we're gonna need a little more
we're gonna even it out here
I'll put it back up no actually it looks
good
how are you gonna find such I don't know
how have you ever find such thin that's
also from Target non-striking uh utensil
tinsel yeah that's tinsel I I think it's
stencil now when you went in did you
throw it in the thing were you pissed
were you driving were you drinking
Target I can tell you where I literally
can tell you her buy what you bought I
can tell exactly how you body threw it
and that you're like oh and you probably
did have the medulla in the car right
you are pissed you put it down I don't
think you brought it in no I didn't I
know I only drink and drive I don't you
definitely drink and drive yeah there's
no way it doesn't drink a job of course
I do guys what are we talking about yeah
don't go around Beverly Boulevard in
Fairfield
and the mugs too I got those for y'all
super they're cute I do like the mugs a
lot cool
um and then did you consider and you
considered which one on which I didn't
do that but it kind of worked out
because you're like the strength of the
podcast you're like the tree of the
podcast strong like true you're the
strength I'm the [ __ ] Doughboy
and you're Santa but Esther is not Santa
no Esther is and she's not I don't know
what Esther is she's that the candle
she's the menorah yeah
yeah
Carlito
what's that way what's the best present
you guys have ever gotten and what's the
worst present ever got PS5 last year oh
do you got it back from who my mom
this is crazy yeah
you're a grown man
I didn't ask for it it just got up it
just showed up really yeah I didn't say
mom I want a PlayStation five I went the
home to Texas and the PlayStation 5 was
there and she like asked around what do
people want what do what do guys she
does ask me what I want sometimes and
this year I was like oh well I could use
a new iPad
well that was extra special to PS5
because I was very hard to come by last
year I know for Bobby's 50th it took I
paid like double the price yeah she got
it on stock it hurt for you too didn't
it it sure did I love it I like paying
double
no I like getting a thing when I want it
I like being like Oh Tim Dylan I told
you Tim Dylan called me once he goes
Annie money fixes everything and ever
since he said that Japan was like yeah
it does but I was like I was gonna get
the um Uggs that Esther has the like the
platform ones but they're sold out
everywhere and then I was like it's too
many people have them if they're that
sold out that I don't want them anymore
dogs the short ones yeah the short ones
even though they're so cute I just want
you know what if they're sold out
everywhere they're two I want to come up
with a new one yeah a different one but
I was like should I spend I think they
were like for 350 bucks you could get
them Tim Dylan is Right money can
absolutely buy happiness it just cannot
prevent sadness he didn't say that he
said money can fix everything oh yeah
yeah except no it cannot because it
cannot fix sadness what I'm saying like
it can drastically improve your life but
it's not going to prevent you from yeah
your dips but it was interesting to
learn like that you can kind of just pay
to have your credit fixed yeah stuff
like that like things that when I was
broke like did you do that yeah that's
awesome wait Annie you don't have a
criminal record you don't know you know
I asked myself the same thing all the
time like how did I I bust in loud I'm
loud people are like there's no way
she's doing what we think she's doing
that is true that's a good do you not
have a criminal record you see
she thought though I like that you had
to think about it yeah I'm
I'm pretty good yeah you have you ever
been detained in your life
no
um I get stopped all the time by cops
and I think I think part of it is the
glasses like maybe I don't know if I
feel like a stoner or something they
think I'm a stoner and they like search
my car and they don't find anything and
then
you allow them to well I've so the last
time it happened I said no because
people were like well you can tell them
no yeah and this and then they brought
out the dog and then they're like well
if my dog barks then we're gonna search
it and I was like all right and sure
enough he's like pulls on the Dodge
chain and he Parks I swear to God it was
all a sudden and they don't find that
thing and yeah the worst time but it
actually ended up being funny was I was
doing a going from San Diego to Phoenix
so we're close to the border and they
stopped us at the border me and my
friend and they were searching my car
forever but I was doing a sketch comedy
show so there are all these props oh
funny they're like pulling out like a
rubber song
like all these scarves and that's really
he's all laughing at this point I'm like
glad you're having fun
I've never had my car searched never
I've never been in a drunk tank either
no I told you when I got pulled over
drunk and but I was friends with all the
guys I was when I was an alcoholic in
Santa Fe I just became friends with all
the cops I was like pre-med like I knew
what was going to happen I think that
was pretty privileged like do you think
if you were yeah yeah but I also worked
these [ __ ] I was friends of
them I sometimes get DMS from people
like it's Fred I'm like What's Up red
red
he's like how you doing you're still
drinking at brunch no baby it's better
to just be nice to make friends with
people than be confrontational from the
start yeah but I used to think it was
funny when I was drunk to take pictures
with cops so I would always like when I
was wasted I would like you know because
the cops and drunk people always eat at
the same places because they're open
late yeah you know in a small town so we
were always together it's like what am I
gonna like act weird around them and I
wasn't into like Coke or anything so I
wasn't doing anything like illegal until
I got into the car yeah so I was just
like you know I would just go over and
be like can we take a pit I just thought
it was so funny because I would be like
eyelash on my cheek wasted like bug
so I had all these pictures of them and
then we just became friends I also was
friends with the um the guy the parking
guy the parking ticket guy and uh the
meter maid and
um so whenever I park my scooter in like
crazy places did you ever have a scooter
yeah like a razor yeah oh okay because
you have scooter energy like I do I
think uh no like you like a vegetable
soup yeah I've always wanted one of
those but yeah you would [ __ ] you
would [ __ ] rock it but um I think
you've passed that place in your time in
your life yeah because we're too like
grown up to get on the [ __ ] on a
Vespa we got places to go we got good
lives yeah that's what like Todd I've
got in fights with Todd because the only
thing that annoys me about Todd ever is
sometimes when he's wasted he's like too
drunk to realize he's drunk and wants to
drive and I'm like I have to be like I
have a beautiful life I have worked so
hard to have I am so happy you are not
taking me out Annie you can't you drink
and drive in the Tesla though
uh
I don't know where the Z is in Tesla but
uh
no I don't put it on Auto Drive or
whatever no you stop to be present and
doing you have to put it on drunk driver
yeah I feel like the Tesla was designed
I feel like the Tesla was designed so
you can text and drive oh it's easy to
text wait don't they have those cars or
did I imagine seeing this where you have
to blow into this thing and it's like a
breathalyzer DUI before the car starts
yeah yeah that's sport mandated oh so it
is a thing that is the thing from the
court
so [ __ ] do you yeah there's this girl
Gabby lamby do you know who she is yeah
yeah she is she she had a DUI back in
the day
and I remember she'd post on Instagram
like sexy like blowing her thing
pictures it was so [ __ ] yeah her
videos were awesome yeah it was so funny
it was I remember Halloween when that
was happening and she was just like a
clown outfit
really funny
it's so good but um yeah so I was
friends with the cops so they like would
pull me over and I remember being like
all right I have to call my because I
can never find my like I couldn't find
my
any of the papers I needed I was like I
don't know where the registration is so
I went to call my mom and they were like
your parents are asleep they're in
Philadelphia they're like do not call
your parents and I was like okay
they're like we'll just follow you home
just go home and they weren't there
anymore I want to ask you guys something
on tigerbelly I briefly mentioned this
but I was talking I had a long heart to
heart with soci bacon and she was like
Lila like just be free like and she was
talking about sex in general because I
have this like fixation about like
hygiene and I think you do too like
we're always like we have to be like
super washed and clean yeah before sex
um I want to know if you think
um or for me I feel like I'm I've missed
out on really fun sex sex spontaneous
sex opportunities because I've always
wanted to like be super squeaky clean
before sex and if I'm I feel like I'm
ready to enter like my filthy girl era
yeah you gotta have stinky sex well you
didn't have them in your long-term
relationships never because Todd's
always like I like your stick you know
like
I like everything about you I like when
you smell I like everything but do you
just like say do you let him then yeah I
do but I'm not gonna like have him like
eat me out when I smell bad that's what
I'm saying I want that God I want to be
able to be brave enough to be like here
oh because then they kiss you I've done
it and it's then it's on me then they
kiss I'm like Ah that's what I felt like
I'm like no
then I know and then it's like oh it's
like more about me it's like oh it's
gonna get back to me Todd yesterday was
like because like boys like how often do
your balls it should they just [ __ ] all
the time not all the time he may have
something if he doesn't have them all
the time but I'm saying I always see
guys with their hands like it you know a
couple times a day I'll squeeze yeah my
[ __ ] itches like frequently I am like
my hand is I'm out bunding most of the
time
there's a place there's like a spot
where I kind of just rest my finger
that's kind of a tuck up area it's like
it's above the [ __ ] it's not touching
vaginal area but it's like you know it's
like there's a little pocket of like
fupa yeah and it's got to be this um
finger motion right here it's milk yeah
yeah but I kind of just chill there
sometimes not with the nails it's been a
while but um so it's not like my hands
are always smelling like do you ever
like
go to hot yoga
and you're like this and then you're
like oh
like I didn't wash my hands like I yeah
I'm like a pretty masturbating girl like
I'm one of those kids masturbating
masturbating maybe touching myself in
person but I noticed my boyfriends have
always been that way too or whatever I
had a boyfriend who like one of his
ticks was like he didn't even know one
of his dicks one of his ticks several
dicks
um there is a guy with dude do dicks
with two dicks right what yeah
that in my life no Oh I thought you were
like that I told you about I was like no
I no
but go ahead but he would like like
without noticing he'd just kind of like
tap like he's got his pants on but he
would just tap the area where his pieces
and then I'm like but it's like you
can't take him around what are you
looking at okay man with
put it up on the screen
see whoa wow somewhere right on top and
somewhere side by side lazy do you think
is better juicy the side by side or up
and down this is I would think up and
down because it's like DP like one for
the ass yeah why do they only circumcise
one though but maybe side by side
because then you don't have to use them
both if you don't want to I would just
put both in one
whoa yeah that's all my hole up
completely I got porn I've never this is
crazy
yeah and why aren't they small dicks
it's like they're they're like these
guys are blessed
they do have one that's like better for
the ass too look at that one it's like a
little skinnier I love that you have the
option like if you're not feeling extra
you can choose the smaller one on
someday the bigger one if you're feeling
a little bit more you know
look
oh my God you're just naturally
ambidextrous because you got to be able
to jerk with both hands I wonder if they
ever go like this to feel like the
stranger all right
wow that's crazy juicy here's why I say
the side by side is better than top
bottom is because for masturbation
purposes it's it's harder to jerk off
like this versus like this it's funnier
though
yeah
you're right though that's I would be so
annoyed when people are like how big is
your dick he's like which one yeah
he'd be all proud of it like do they
like when they first meet a girl do they
have to tuck one of the dicks because
they're too nervous I don't want her to
know yet
wait can we look at those again I want
to see what the ball situation was with
them do they have four balls no balls no
no balls two dicks no balls one ball oh
no ball are there really no balls I
don't see them they're out of there in
that one
um
[Laughter]
this is crazy wait I feel like some of
these are not real I feel like that one
might be he has a vagina too and tooth
diaphalic incredible oh he has an
Instagram die felt like a dude
what is it what how long is it how many
inches was that it looks like it's a six
or eight oh my God two eight inchers
that's 16 inches
yeah hey Jesus this is crazy it's like
liquid at the top of one of them yeah
sometimes yeah
this is this is Carlos trying to pretend
he doesn't know what dicks do this is a
great Christmas episode Merry Christmas
guys I mean this is quite a present time
wrap
wow no this stuff I want you guys to I
want this to happen to a gay man too
because I feel like men's sexuality like
their horniness is like
yeah not like a frigid [ __ ] that
eventually is going to be like oh you
make the one come you're like another
wait I have a question do you think both
come at the same time I was just gonna
do they yeah
can we find a double dick person to call
into the um live show can we hit up guy
phallic dude yes oh my God maybe he can
video chat us
I just I just don't want to see his eyes
I want to see what if he has
everything's weird he only has one eye
like everything's off everything that's
true how many ounces no arms no arms but
do you need arms when you have two dicks
oh my God and his penis can like he has
to eat his food of this penis
I knew there there was this woman that
had um
her arms were like underdeveloped that
used to come into my restaurant and she
would have this like thing that would
velcro around and then that's where she
would put her fork and she would eat
like that oh so maybe we could do that
with the penis yeah maybe
gotta be good at yoga what was that
it's his
it's the diphalic dudes Twitter how many
followers it's
only are you serious why is it all twos
yeah because he's a student also I feel
like you can make eight dollars and he's
playing Two Trumpets
[Laughter]
whoa he does two of everything I am I'm
in a committed polyamorous relationship
but sometimes things get complicated
French tag smell yo dick wait why was it
2014 this is a dead person if diaphalic
dude is dead I'm quitting the show oh my
God I think he might be dead he's
definitely dead where's he been I mean
probably dealing with double dick stuff
maybe do you think the rigor mortis they
they said in and he had boners I would
offer my body to science if I were him
right
to like be like as it mounted somewhere
it's like it's more common than we think
though with all those things yes there's
so many of them we've got to find a
double dick a different double but
aren't there ladies with two vaginas yes
look up double vagina girls wait well
here it says it only affects about one
out of every five to six million that's
a lot
all right let me see about vaginas
because they'd be perfect this is gonna
be crazy
[Applause]
Shin that only happens in about one in
every 3 000 women that's that's common
that's a lot right yeah born with two
vaginas not so rare ABC News look up
pictures we don't want to hear news
you know what's funny is I didn't even
think of the pictures of the vaginas
yeah
Carlos just say it just be yourself
save it for the life I feel like they're
better about because the vagina has been
aren't showing the vagina the guys are
like taking so many pictures but the
women are not taking pictures of the
women are like I don't want anyone to
see this I'm ashamed
oh my God it looked like the vaginas are
within the vagina though it didn't look
like
they were stacked I want them like side
by side vaginal Inception yeah I think
they are this is from the Atlantic this
is what looks like a bat
it's a the [ __ ] is that girl did a
diagram show us your [ __ ] but she's hot
too let me see your badge yeah there's
an only fans creator with it
one maybe oh my God should oh no we
can't
all right there it is
I I get it now
that's yeah I've understood I feel like
there's two entries but one cervix why
does she have two eyes above them okay
okay let's see yeah it looks like a
Oscar the crowd she does
oh I guess it's just there's like
two oh the holes I wanted the whole
thing
the Fallopian tubes look like those in
comic books where it's like Pals yeah
bam I wonder if a double dick guy and a
double vagina girl have ever fallen in
love I hope so and they didn't know it
they didn't know that yeah it was just
they were naturally into each other and
then they found that they were siblings
and then kalila was like
straight to only have
oh dreams a girl can dream oh wait so
Todd the other day he tried to touch me
with his like ball hand I saw him take
his hand out of his like ball area and I
go no no no
you're gonna touch me with ball hand he
started laughing right and then like
five minutes past and we kind of like
forgot about ball hand and he reached
over us a bit and went like this and it
was ball hand and I went as he was
touching my eyelism it's ball hand and
he laughs so [ __ ] hard
I had a I I had a friend who was just
the nastiest [ __ ] but like girls
would be like I have a herpes outbreak
he's like I don't care I'll eat you out
and he was like I'm Invincible he never
he's a cokehead that is so Cokey to be
like sore I don't give a [ __ ] your
[ __ ] sores but he ended up getting
like double ocular herpes yeah like he
would have like like weepy crusty
um it was I mean he know he took chances
in life it looked a lot like the double
vagina
now have you ever done cocaine never
I've ever done any drugs outside of Weed
and Alcohol
now I did
I did have one experience with Coke that
was not in high school more recently
it is not good yeah not a good drug it
is not I feel like it is like it's lame
it's a loser it's a loser drug it's so
lame and but it's so addictive like I
don't why do you think it's addictive
because it's so not a big deal of a high
like you're not like it sounds like a
good idea and then you're doing it and
it's like I think
you just keep wanting more when you do
it because it's not good yeah it's not
good it's not I never like anything is
it a high or you just really amped it's
a high like you'll probably like be
happy to talk for a long time but like I
think like something like Adderall is a
much better High yeah Adderall it's like
just go to Adderall where it's like a
more like contained thing and you can
actually get stuff done has anyone does
anyone ever like do Coke and then get
their work done or are they just like
coming up with ideas like Wall Street
guys do that yeah yeah Finance Bros do
that like I've heard of that which seems
insane I just it was making me so sad I
was like I was like this is what it is
like I just did a little bit but I was
just like this is like
what people die from is that this is how
they feel and then they die it's like so
sadly things like Molly like Molly seems
way more fun oh
Molly ish Molly is fun
mommy is like a fun what is this thing
there's a there's a grinch somewhere
this is a weird mine it's a it's a pain
here you just I can hold it okay that is
very weird it doesn't look right I think
it's in backwards like these are
supposed to go on this side
well okay so cocaine just feels like
icky like it's like it's like you're my
for me it's like my voice and my body
are going at a different pace so then I
don't even like talking it's like I love
to talk and it's like sucks to have all
these good ideas because I'm all like oh
I got a Coke idea and then uh I can't
even express it's just so I don't like
it all I think about the whole time I do
it is how I can do more yeah like
literally I'm just like I can't wait to
do it more of it and then and then I
just feel gross the next day and yeah it
gives you like a bad hangover it's also
by the way snow that's why it's on this
episode snow
well you're wondering what I'm curious
to um if you were to ever be inclined to
do this is Coke ideas one page coca when
you're next time you do Coke write
everything you're thinking next time you
do weed right everything you're thinking
then ketamine then acid then mushrooms
and compare each version of yourself I
used to do that when I because I used to
experiment with drugs a lot and my the
mushroom ones and like acid notes
you have no idea what I was writing but
it made so much sense at the time I was
like this is amazing is that Doodles
well it's like sentences that don't end
and you know and like yeah and they're
like it's not in a written like a
regular way and it just makes no sense
so here's a spider's webs on different
drugs oh wow I've seen this yeah
marijuana
thean
I like the marijuana when it just stops
working falls asleep
and benzos just like erratic it would be
like that's like Coke and then the
chloral hydrates are like Coke like I
don't need a home like I don't need it
yeah what is life yeah very very
um not ambitious on chlorohydrate I feel
like the normal person is very ambitious
when I used to smoke weed
I would always even though I knew it was
destroying my life I'm not saying that
for other people I actually think it's
very good for the one that sits there
but um the one who shall not be
mentioned but does sit there
um
you're talking about Esther right okay
we don't mention our get my legs off
she's Jewish is the Christmas episode we
do not bring her up
um
but I would do like little things like I
would do I was taking like a typing
online typing no I didn't pay for it I
just found an online typing course
that's so cute and I would do it over
the pandemic isn't it cute I like I like
when you tell me like you do drugs and
then you say things like 10 seconds
after like I took an online typing
course yeah I'm always showing it better
well that's why I don't like drugs like
Coke and stuff I like I like to do drugs
that are like making me better yeah yeah
that are like helping me figure stuff
out or whatever which Coke is crazy I
just I guess I just like you know it's
like it's
glamorize like in the 80s type thing but
it also is always and people die I just
can't believe that's what people died
from I don't like being around it either
I think it's sometimes it's hard to say
no to for me
um but also I don't like like if I'm not
doing it it's usually not a good ground
people yeah it's like everyone's like
got like foamy mouths and crusty noses
and yeah nasty it's yeah it's usually
not a good it's just not the pacing it's
like when you're in it you're like oh
this is the pacing and when you're out
of it watching you're like that's
another amazing yes do you think that
maybe someone Molly too though watching
people on Molly is like they're all like
rubbing themselves you already have like
a natural energy about you do you think
that maybe someone a little bit more
subdued and kind of like low energy
would enjoy something like Coke a little
bit more eyes people get addicted to it
so they must but I don't don't recommend
it it sucks do not do it I don't think
it matters what your energy is it just
takes over you completely like Annie and
Esther doing coke I think it would have
the same effect they would both just
start talking like crazy and feel like
[ __ ] later yeah it's just not a positive
like I feel like even with like ketamine
even though I've been known to probably
do it too much but I always then know I
do it too much and then stop doing it
because because it's one of those things
where you want to like you want to reap
the benefits of it you know you want to
have like the moment where you're kind
of
feeling good again
and then yeah but with weed I would do
my typing class because it's like a
timed thing you do like the F and the H
or whatever I'm [ __ ] remember
um
but you know like you'd work on like
your different like because I never I
skipped that class because I used to get
headaches so I never did type in class
so now I'm like it takes me so long to
type yeah especially with oh the nails
it's a wrap yeah you should writing for
the roast I was like okay I dubbed Todd
right on my joke
I was like Todd type he's like just give
it to me I'm not letting you type this
there's so annoying to watch but it but
I was so much slower and I just couldn't
get stuff done because I think I was
trying to convince myself that maybe
weed like does have a benefit for me
maybe it does help me but whatever the
medicine is in weed is not a medicine I
need I'm not like ailing in the way that
weed can help you right so it did not
but I was always just trying to find one
thing that would be like okay I smoke
weed that's helping you and I never
could hmm yeah I want to smoke more weed
but it it ends up making me depressed
yeah it's like when I don't have it I
think that's like when you were saying
earlier you end up smoking every day for
five days yeah because like there is a
there is a calm down especially if you
don't if you stopped so your tolerance
is already so low yep and then yeah and
so it's better for me if I pretty much
just stay away from it every once in a
while if I'm partying I'll like smoke
part of a joint or something but yeah I
had to just give myself like um it's
same with cigarettes like I have to just
be like I just don't smoke because yeah
I get so and I think it's from smoking
cigarettes too like I love smoking
joints but I don't necessarily like
being high but I don't want to smoke
cigarettes I don't want to smoke a joint
then I'm like oh my God and there'll be
like times where I was smoking like CBD
I'm like what am I doing I did that too
no reason it's like just like all this
like addiction I was like you know what
I have to just like in those moments
where I'm feeling like I want something
like chill with myself and push through
it but with you I feel like you're going
through a breakup a life trend position
all this stuff and you already do the
things that other people do to get out
of that funk where you exercise and you
take care of yourself so you already do
that yeah so you don't have that to use
as like a thing to sort of change your
your life a little bit because I think
it's good to always have like especially
as comedians
and um I'm sure for everyone in their
lives it's good to have like new fan of
phases like you shift your yeah you're
not doing the same thing every day juicy
um you've been a part of bad friends for
how long now since June it was right
around my birthday uh when I turned 32
and so in June
um so I don't know however long that is
from India and in the event of a
drowning and you could only say one
would you save Bobby or Santino poppy
would flow look at him yeah his name's
Bob look at that
well
man
that I would I would think I think
Santino would would want me to say Bobby
oh that is so not true not true at all I
feel like and Bobby but if you save
Bobby he would also like [ __ ] with you
be like you should have saved Santino no
Bobby would like [ __ ] with you if I
saved Santino and Bobby lived he would
kill me he would kill me but also
Santino has more life I would be saving
him and then I'd feel something grab my
leg
you'd be done in this time to be like I
brought you into this world I'll take
you out yeah
he always likes to remind me how much
he's helped me
I mean that's a wonderful thing about
him he's like there's no one more
generous but there's no one
um more
um there's no one who loves to remind
you more about how much he's helped yeah
than him yeah I love it I'm very
grateful to both of them though they've
yeah there's been like a wee joke about
it too there's been like a
um a bidding war almost it was like
people bringing me out to feed yeah yeah
this would really find like a great part
of like a great journey I remember when
you first started with bad friends Bobby
was like I just have a feeling I'm not
wrong about her I just have a feeling
this is even before you were on bad
friends and he and as soon as he did the
first episode he came back and he was
like she [ __ ] killed it I knew it I
[ __ ] knew it oh yeah I got your
shoulders that makes me feel so good
yeah his approval is exciting because
from what I've heard he doesn't like a
lot of people he hates everyone yeah so
it feels like it feels I don't know why
that it shouldn't feel good
knowing Bobby I found out we'd been in a
war right
right
so much for tuning in to our Christmas
episode we hope you have the most
amazing warm cozy holidays and if it is
depressing that's okay don't do Coke by
the way don't do it the whole reason
we're bringing up is like don't do it
it's [ __ ] lame January 18th or 19th
18th 18th she's doing one night only you
gotta come go see her at the San Jose
Improv thank you thank you thank you
Merry Christmas guys thanks guys bye
foreign
[Music]